- SO WHAT ARE GUYS
ACTUALLY THINKING DURING SEX?
- I THINK
EVERY GUY'S MIND WANDERS.
- FOR THE MOST PART,
THEY'RE JUST IN THE MOMENT
ENJOYING THE SENSATION.
- OKAY, SO WHAT MAKES A GIRL
GOOD IN BED?
- YEAH, JUST GOODNESS.
- REACTING AND NOT BEING LIKE,
"HERE ARE MY THINGS.
"HERE WE GO.
THIS IS WHAT I DO."
- WHAT DOES THE INSIDE
OF THE VAGINA
FEEL LIKE?
- PERFECTION.
- THERE'S RIDGES IN THERE.
- IT'S SOFT
AND, LIKE, VELVETY.
- OKAY, I'M PRETTY SURE
THAT GUY
DOESN'T KNOW WHAT THE INSIDE
OF A VAGINA FEELS LIKE.
"IT FEELS LIKE YOUR HAND
BUT SLIMIER."
AND HOW DO GIRLS NOT KNOW
WHAT THEIR VAGINA FEELS LIKE?
THOSE ARE THE QUESTIONS
BUZZFEED THINKS
WOMEN WANT ANSWERS TO.
JUST STICK TO MAKING QUIZZES
THAT HELP PEOPLE FIND OUT
WHAT TYPE OF DELI MEAT THEY ARE.
I'M SUCH A SALAMI.
WHAT MAKES A GIRL GOOD IN BED?
BEING REALLY, REALLY HOT.
DO ANY GIRLS IN THIS AUDIENCE
HAVE ANY REAL QUESTIONS FOR MEN?
- WHY ARE GUYS
SO AGAINST GETTING MARRIED?
- I'M NOT AGAINST IT,
BUT MARRIAGE
IS FOR GAY PEOPLE.
LIKE, I--HONESTLY.
IT'S FOR GAY PEOPLE AND WOMEN.
THAT'S IT.
NO STRAIGHT MAN
WANTS TO PLAY DRESS UP
AND STAND IN FRONT OF
ALL OF HIS FRIENDS AND FAMILY
AND MAKE PROMISES
TO NEVER LOVE ANYBODY ELSE.
IT'S JUST STUPID.
- HOW MANY GIRLS
HAVE YOU SLEPT WITH?
- I'M AT A NUMBER NOW
WHERE WHEN A GIRL
COMES UP TO ME,
I HAVE TO ASK MYSELF,
"DID I SLEEP WITH THIS GIRL,
OR IS THIS
A COMPLETE STRANGER?"
I'D SAY IT'S SOMEWHERE
IN THE 290s.
WHO'S NEXT?
- HAVE YOU EVER CHEATED
ON SOMEONE?
- ONLY WITH MY HEART.
WHO'S NEXT?
- DO YOU CONSIDER YOURSELF
GOOD IN BED?
- NO.
[stammers]
I FINISH.
- WHY ARE GUYS OBSESSED
WITH ANAL?
- WHY DOES THE WIND BLOW?
WHY DID LEWIS AND CLARK
PUSH PAST ST. LOUIS?
EXPLORATION!
THE QUESTION SHOULD BE,
WHY ARE LADIES SO SCARED OF IT?
- DO YOU THINK I'M PRETTY?
- PHYSICALLY NO.
BUT YOUR CONFIDENCE,
SOME WOULD FIND
VERY ATTRACTIVE,
IF YOU WERE MUCH PRETTIER.
ALL RIGHT, THIS IS WHY
MEN AND WOMEN SHOULDN'T TALK.